量子コンピューティングは実用の時代に突入しました
つまり、量子コンピューターを使って問題を解き始めることが
できるようになったということです。中には古典コンピューターには
非常に難しい問題も含まれています
現在の時代に共通するテーマとして
ある問題が初めて
量子コンピューターで解かれ
その後、古典コンピューターでも解く方法が見つかる
というサイクルがあります。この古典コンピューティングと
量子コンピューティングがお互いの限界を
押し広げるサイクルは、おそらく続くでしょう
しばらくの間は、量子コンピューティングが
証明可能な優位性を持つ問題のクラスがあります
古典コンピューティングに対して
エラーの削減などの分野での進展や
利用可能なqubitの数が増えれば、その優位性は高まります
また、アプリケーション領域全体として
量子コンピューティングが
比較的近い将来に役立つ可能性のある分野もあります
そのような分野の一つが、量子機械学習（QML）です
量子機械学習とは
量子コンピューティングをあらゆる種類の機械
学習プロセスに応用することです。もちろん
機械学習には多くの種類があります
特に注目すべき2つのタイプは
教師あり学習と教師なし学習です。教師あり学習では
ラベル付きデータセットを使ってアルゴリズムを訓練します
教師なし学習では
アルゴリズムがラベルなしのサンプルから学習し
その分布について理解しようとします
またはそれを生成する関数について
教師なしアルゴリズムは例えば
同じ分布から新しいサンプルを生成する方法を学んだり
または似たような特性を持つグループに
サンプルをクラスタリングする方法を学んだりします
教師ありと教師なし学習のどちらも、多くの場合
データをより高次元の空間に埋め込む処理が含まれます
そして高次元空間でのデータ操作というと
量子コンピューティングを思い浮かべるはずです
その理由を説明しましょう。平面上のデータ点が
丸か×かを分類するという問題を
解くことを考えてみてください。ここにはラベル付きの訓練データがあります
データが直線でくっきり分けられる場合もあります
低次元での平面など
このように示されており、直線の上下でデータ点を分類するのは
線より上のデータ点と
線より下のデータ点を分けるのは
問題ないはずです。でも、この分布を見てください
データ点を分けられる直線が明らかに見当たりません
しかし、このデータに対しては何らかの
2次元から3次元へのマッピングが考えられます
そのマッピングを適用した後、データは
このようになり、2つのクラスを分ける平面が明確に存在します
その平面を分類に
利用できます。この説明が少し単純すぎると感じたなら
その通りです。データ点を単に
理由なく上方向に移動させることはできません
マッピングが必要です
2次元の分布から、データ点を
効果的に分離するマッピングが必要です。そうして
そのマッピングを使って新しいデータ点を分類します
これについては、機械学習の復習を行うレッスンで
詳しく説明しますが、要点を言えば
この問題は
この高次元空間への様々なマッピングを試して
どのマッピングが異なるクラスの
データ点を最もよく分離するかを見つける問題として見ることができます
この高次元でのデータ操作は
量子コンピューティングが
大きな影響を与えられる分野の一つです。その理由を理解するために
古典コンピューティングと
量子コンピューティングの違いに戻りましょう。
古典コンピューターが情報のビットを使うように
量子コンピューターはqubitを使います
しかし、ある一定のビット数、例えば4ビットの場合
古典コンピューターは
2の4乗、つまり16通りの可能な状態のいずれかを取れます
量子コンピューターも同様に16通りの状態にアクセスできますが
すべての16の状態の重ね合わせとして
同時に存在することができます
そして、その重ね合わせ全体に対して演算を実行できます
4つのqubitではそれほど大きなことに
思えないかもしれませんが、2の20乗、あるいは
量子コンピューターで2の20乗または
2の127乗で何ができるかを想像してみてください
これらの状態を同時に扱えます。古典コンピューティングと
量子コンピューティングの間には他にも多くの違いがあり
それらすべてがこの分野で重要な役割を果たします
量子状態は複素確率振幅を持ちます
量子システムの操作はユニタリ演算子で行われ
量子コンピューターは古典コンピューターとは異なる種類の
ノイズの影響を受けます
これらの違いは
量子機械学習の研究の中で、データエンコーディング、
特徴マッピング、エラー緩和といった分野で登場してきます
場合によっては、古典コンピューターと
量子コンピューターのこれらの違いにより、まったく
新しいアルゴリズムを設計できるようになります。以上は
非常に複雑な2つの分野の融合についての
簡単な概観でした。しかし、少なくとも2点は
明確になったはずです。機械学習はしばしば
非常に高い次元でデータを操作することで問題を解きます
そして第二に、量子コンピューターは
高次元でのデータ操作に適しており
古典システムとは異なる方法でそれを行います
これで、なぜ機械学習が
有望な分野であるかがわかるでしょう
量子コンピューティングの実用的な応用として